la vacuna contra el jove 19 ya está en
américa latina' del primer cargamento
fue recibido en ciudad de mexico la
esperanza para una región que aglutina
el 30 por ciento de los fallecimientos y
cerca de un 20% de los contagios por
kobe 19 a nivel mundial luego la vacuna
oigo a nuestra población decirlo con
entusiasmo y esperanza
con el apoyo directo del señor
presidente de mexico el licenciado
andrés manuel lópez obrador hoy es un
día para recordar como lo es el año 2020
que todos quisiéramos olvidar por
razones de logística y la necesaria
ultracongelación estas primeras 3.000
dosis se van a aplicar en la ciudad de
mexico y en saltillo con énfasis en el
personal médico la idea es que para el
31 de enero haya 1,4 millones de dosis y
75 millones en marzo un alivio que por
estos 10 se encuentra en la capital una
problemática añadida la dificultad para
conseguir oxígeno varios ciudadanos
denuncian problemas de escasez para
obtener estos tanques con una ocupación
hospitalaria del 80 por ciento algunos
prefieren tener oxígeno en casa y tratar
hacia los suyos y ya llevo toda la
semana pasada y estoy no hay oxígeno no
necesita desde el gobierno local pide en
calma y asegura que están tratando la
situación pero mientras pasan los días
se está notando un aumento en los
precios del oxígeno los tanques de 680
litros han pasado de 150 a 200 dólares